[Applause]
now let's bring back commissioner silver
to present the 2023 Bill Russell NBA
Finals Most Valuable Player award
this is the first Finals MVP trophy that
we're giving out since Bill Russell's
passing
and he'd be incredibly pleased it's
another Center
this year's Bill Russell Finals MVP goes
to Nicola jokic
thank you
[Applause]
Nicola you've said that you never
envisioned any of this for yourself
being an All-Star two-time MVP and now a
Finals MVP but what does it mean to you
to now just Just To Be A Champion to be
able to celebrate with their family you
know Adrian said really one really good
thing we are we are not winning for
ourselves we have anything for the for
the the guy next to us and that's why
this more is even more because uh I was
waiting for Jamal tomorrow
and uh this is a great group of people a
great group of teammates
[Music]
everything this this year was amazing
what are you most proud of about this
team you know we believe in each other
the relationship that we had uh yes
trophies in something but I think we had
some relationship but it's going to be a
long longer like even even after me
finish careers
thank you Nicola congratulations to talk
to your teammate Jamal